Oh
more and more now I feel that your
budget should just not matter you should
you should give up the idea that
spending money is the key to having a
great and successful trip or adventure
once you put aside that that idea that
the travel and money are related that
the more you spend the better you travel
then you suddenly everything becomes
open to you when you say I don't need to
spend money I don't need to spend money
to have a good meal I don't need to
spend a lot of money to have a nice
place to stay I don't need to spend a
lot of money to get from point A to
point B then you have to be more
creative you you find other ways to to
travel you find other places other kinds
of places to stay I just got back from a
trip walking from Vienna Austria through
slovakia and down to budapest hungary
it's about 300 kilometers and i was in
these little towns that didn't have
hotels or restaurants or much of
anything and people are constantly
offering me meals offering to be places
to stay these were things that happened
not because i said i only have a limited
amount of money to spend but because
spending money was sort of beside the
point I could have spent a lot of money
in these towns and it wouldn't have
gotten me anything I wouldn't well if
I'd spent a lot of money first of all I
wouldn't have wound up in these towns in
the first place and if I had you know
having a hundred years night to spend on
a hotel in a town that doesn't have a
hotel it doesn't get you anything you
know whether you've got five euros or
100 euros or a thousand euros to spend
the night in an interesting place the
place that you get for free or the place
that you get that's run by someone small
and creative and clever is going to be
much better than the place that you get
simply because you have money
I learned something about walking when
you have 300 kilometers to walk which is
about a hundred and sixty miles I think
you you you learn a couple things about
walking pretty quickly one is that
there's a difference between walking a
lot on your own in a city and walking 15
miles a day with 40 or 45 pounds of gear
on your back my legs are very strong
except for my ankles it turns out so
there were times there were times when I
realized that I wasn't going to make it
unless I took a train for 20 kilometers
and then started walking from there so I
probably walked a well over half the
distance I think it's to 290 kilometers
total and I walk probably about 150 160
of that so uh it was it was tough stuff
my ankle this the cycle still a little
swollen and shouldn't run I'm going to
get fat for the next few days
you see places that no one else has seen
at all no other tourist is going to
places like velky grub and no one walks
into estragon you know these are these
are strange places that they won't
impress anyone when you tell people you
went there but the kind of experiences
that you're gonna have there are just
amazing I mean it people were giving me
places asleep for the night they were
inviting me in for dinner um they were
showing me around offering me rides
helping me in my investigations it was
the people that you meet for me are
definitely the most important part of
the journey you make friends exchange
email addresses you stay in touch with
these people every once in a while to
come to New York or you're traveling
somewhere and you meet them in a third
country and and those kind of
connections are those are the most
important souvenirs is the most
important on the ground experiences you
have when you're traveling and you don't
necessarily get those if you're speeding
through from city to city on a train or
a bus if you're walking you know you
wind up walking next to someone who's
walking their dog and they turn out to
be an English teacher and they invite
you home for backyard wine and sweets
and give you a nice bed to sleep in
that's there's nothing better than that
absolutely that is a really large
country and you know it's not
necessarily a small-town value but it's
a people in America are very friendly
and they often actually want to meet
outsiders and new people I've had that
happen in 2007 I drove from New York to
Seattle sort of zigzagging across the
country staying off the interstates
entirely and in Decorah Iowa I stopped
in this little town in northeast Iowa
one one evening and found a
bed-and-breakfast range to stay there
for the night walk down a hill and found
this cute little bistro la Orana bistro
the Frog and walked in and got a glass
of wine and some bread and cheese of the
counter and started talking to the
owners and about five minutes after they
met me they said hey you need a place to
stay you know they had a lovely house
they had a whole wing of the house with
its own bedroom and bathroom all to
itself that they just offered to me for
three or four days just because they
they like me it was an interesting
traveler who passed it passing through
let's give them a place to stay so yeah
whether you're driving or walking that
that's you know that's going to happen